It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. us like to think we'd stay grounded if we were suddenly to become very wealthy, that we'd still be our old selves, just with more money. But psychologists' research suggests that this might not be true. In recent years, studies have found that gaining money and status can shift how people see themselves and how they behave toward others. While it was the novelist F. Scott Fitzgerald who wrote that the rich are different from you and me, it is psychologists who have shown this to be true. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies wealth and the ways in which the rich are indeed different. How to money, status, and power shape people's behavior and beliefs?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。我们总喜欢认为，如果我们突然变得非常富有，我们依然会脚踏实地，依然是原来的自己，只是钱多了而已。但心理学研究表明，事实可能并非如此。近年来，研究发现，金钱和地位的获得会改变人们的自我认知以及对待他人的方式。虽然是小说家 F·斯科特·菲茨杰拉德写道“富人与你我不同”，但心理学家已经证明了这一点。今天，我们将采访一位研究财富以及富人确实有何不同的心理学家。金钱、地位和权力是如何塑造人们的行为和信念的？
What are the psychological mechanisms at play? And at a time of rising income inequality, what happens to people's sense of empathy, fairness, and entitlement as the gap between rich and poor widens? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Paul Piff, an associate professor of psychological science at the University of California, Irvine, where he leads the morality, emotion, and social hierarchy lab. Dr. Piff studies how economic inequality and social class shape relationships between people and groups. He's published dozens of peer-reviewed research studies and has discussed his research
其中的心理机制是什么？在收入不平等加剧的时代，随着贫富差距的扩大，人们的同理心、公平感和权利感会发生什么变化？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是加州大学欧文分校心理科学副教授保罗·皮夫博士，他在那里领导着道德、情感和社会等级实验室。皮夫博士研究经济不平等和社会阶层如何塑造人与人、群体与群体之间的关系。他发表了数十项同行评审的研究，并讨论了他的研究
widely with media outlets, including the New York Times, the Wall Street Journal, Marketplace, and the PBS News Hour. Dr. Piff, thank you for joining me today. Thanks so much, Kim, for that lovely introduction, and it's a pleasure to be here today. I want to start with a question that you pose in your popular TED talk called, Does Money Make You Mean? In it, you talk about an experiment you did with a rigged game of monopoly. Can you tell our listeners about that research and what you found? Now the rigged game of monopoly was really our attempt in the lab to kind of emulate or model some of the features of being wealthy out in the real world. It's hard to do because money is such a complicated thing and it means so many different things to so many different people and it comes about in so many different ways in people's lives.
广泛见诸媒体，包括《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》、《Marketplace》和《PBS 新闻一小时》。皮夫博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。非常感谢，金，感谢您如此美好的介绍，很高兴今天能来到这里。我想从您在广受欢迎的 TED 演讲中提出的一个问题开始，题目是《金钱会让你变得刻薄吗？》。在演讲中，您谈到了一个用操纵过的“大富翁”游戏所做的实验。您能告诉我们的听众关于这项研究以及您的发现吗？那个被操纵的“大富翁”游戏实际上是我们实验室试图模拟或建模现实世界中富有生活某些特征的尝试。这很难做到，因为金钱是一个非常复杂的东西，对不同的人意味着不同的东西，并且在人们的生活中以各种不同的方式出现。
But we wanted to come up with a situation in the lab that allowed us to within sort of this canned situation of a, laboratory environment, create between people the experience of being, relatively speaking, richer or poor. That's a question that's dogged social scientists for decades, because you can't just randomly assign people in the real world to being millionaires or to being impoverished and then following them over the course of their lives. But we thought within a game of monopoly, which everyone's familiar with, or many people are, you could create within just 10 or 15 minutes, some of the experiences of being wealthy or less wealthy. And so what we did was brought, we brought in pairs of strangers to the lab,
但我们想在实验室中创造一种情境，让我们能够在实验室这种受控的环境中，在人与人之间创造出相对富有或贫穷的体验。这是一个困扰社会科学家几十年的问题，因为你不能在现实世界中随机分配人们成为百万富翁或穷人，然后跟踪他们的一生。但我们认为，在每个人都熟悉或许多人都熟悉的“大富翁”游戏中，你可以在短短 10 或 15 分钟内创造出一些富有或不那么富有的体验。所以我们所做的是，我们带了成对的陌生人来到实验室，
and they didn't know each other. They didn't know what kind of situation they were walking in on. It's just a psychology study after all. We told them they were going to get to play a game, and to play the game, we were first going to flip a coin. And we flipped a coin to randomly decide who of those two players, who of those two participants in our study would get to be a rich versus poor player in the game. Now, my collaborators and I leading up to those first sessions had spent months playing
他们互不认识。他们不知道自己将要进入什么样的情境。毕竟这只是一个心理学研究。我们告诉他们将要玩一个游戏，为了玩这个游戏，我们首先要掷硬币。我们掷硬币随机决定这两名玩家中，这两名参与我们研究的参与者中，谁将在游戏中成为富人，谁成为穷人。现在，我和我的合作者在进行这些首次会议之前，已经花了几个月的时间玩
Monopoly and trying to figure out like what does this game need to look like to basically get people who experience being somewhat richer or somewhat poor. And so we had done some piloting and we figured out that the more desirable piece or the most desirable piece in Monopoly was the Rolls-Royce. The least desirable piece in Monopoly was the shoe. So the flip of a coin randomly assigned one person to be a rich player versus a poor player. The rich player got the Rolls Royce. The poor player got the shoe.
“大富翁”，试图弄清楚这个游戏需要是什么样子，才能让人们体验到某种程度的富有或贫穷。所以我们做了一些试点，发现“大富翁”中最令人向往的棋子是劳斯莱斯。最不令人向往的棋子是鞋子。掷硬币随机分配一个人成为富人玩家或穷人玩家。富人玩家得到了劳斯莱斯。穷人玩家得到了鞋子。
The rich player got twice as much money to play the game with. They got $2,000 instead of half of that amount, $1,000. When they passed Go, they'd collect $200. So they got, let's say, two times the salary of the poor player who only collected $100 when they went around the board. and they got to roll two dice instead of one. So they got to move around the board a lot faster. And so over the course of 15 minutes, we just surreptitiously observed and recorded
富人玩家在玩游戏时得到了两倍的钱。他们得到了 2000 美元，而不是一半的金额，即 1000 美元。当他们经过起点时，他们会收到 200 美元。所以，假设他们得到的工资是穷人玩家的两倍，穷人玩家绕过棋盘时只收到 100 美元。而且他们可以掷两个骰子而不是一个。所以他们可以在棋盘上移动得快得多。因此，在 15 分钟的过程中，我们只是悄悄地观察和记录
what happened and what unfolded in this game. And we followed up this game with some surveys where we also measured some other things. But we did this with more than 100 different pairs of strangers. And what we found is that, you know, in broad strokes, over the course of the 15 minutes, what started out as a kind of, certainly an unfamiliar and kind of strange situation quickly became a competitive game between two people. And they were just, you know, within a couple minutes, people were playing monopoly. And obviously, the person who was
游戏中发生了什么，以及事情是如何展开的。我们在游戏结束后进行了一些调查，还测量了其他一些东西。但我们对 100 多对不同的陌生人进行了这项研究。我们发现，你知道，从大体上看，在 15 分钟的过程中，最初那种肯定是不熟悉且有点奇怪的情况，很快就变成了两个人之间的竞争游戏。他们只是，你知道，几分钟之内，人们就在玩“大富翁”了。显然，那个
assigned to be the rich player had double the advantages in so many ways. And we noticed their patterns of behavior begin to shift. They became more dominant in their behavior. They, for instance, started moving around the board in a louder fashion, smacking the board with the piece, with their game piece. They took up more space at the board, so they actually became more expansive in their posture.
被指定为富人玩家的人在很多方面都有双重优势。我们注意到他们的行为模式开始发生转变。他们的行为变得更加强势。例如，他们开始以更响亮的方式在棋盘上移动，用棋子猛击棋盘。他们在棋盘上占据了更多的空间，所以他们的姿势实际上变得更加舒展。
They're more likely to fan their money out than to keep it confined to a little stack. So they were more likely to sort of showcase how well they're doing. And over the course of the game, we noticed that just in their nonverbal behavior to the other person, they became way less sort of sensitive to the plight of the poor players and way more likely to talk about and showcase how well they were doing. So what that tells us a little bit is that you can create this kind of rigged experience of privilege through the flip of a coin and get someone to experience that privilege and actually start to manifest as if they deserve that privilege in certain ways within an experience.
他们比把钱限制在一小叠里更倾向于把钱摊开。所以他们更倾向于炫耀自己做得有多好。在游戏过程中，我们注意到，仅仅从他们对另一个人的非语言行为来看，他们对穷人玩家困境的敏感度大大降低，而且更有可能谈论和炫耀自己做得有多好。所以这告诉我们一点，你可以通过掷硬币创造这种被操纵的特权体验，让某人体验这种特权，并实际上开始表现得好像他们在某种程度上理应获得这种特权。
At the end of the game, when we asked people to describe why the game had ended in the way that they had, and I should say that all rich players inevitably and invariably won the game, of course, they had twice the advantage, obvious. So we asked the rich players, like, why did you win the game? And they were way more likely to talk about the things that they'd done, their skill at the game, their decisions, the properties they bought. They just talk about decisions they've made as opposed to talking about that flip of the coin that randomly and through no action of their own got them to experience that privileged position in the first place. Now, just to tie this back, and you asked me about monopolies.
在游戏结束时，当我们要求人们描述游戏为什么会以这种方式结束时——我应该说，所有富人玩家不可避免地总是赢得了游戏，当然，他们有两倍的优势，显而易见。所以我们问富人玩家，你为什么赢了游戏？他们更有可能谈论他们所做的事情、他们在游戏中的技巧、他们的决定、他们购买的房产。他们只是谈论他们做出的决定，而不是谈论那个随机的、没有任何自身行为就让他们体验到这种特权地位的掷硬币过程。现在，为了把这一点联系起来，你问我关于“大富翁”的问题。
and I talked about wanting to model certain aspects of the real world. And people could quibble. I mean, maybe this is like allegory masquerading as science or science masquerading as allegor. I mean, I think, you know, there's issues with the study. But I think one of the things that strikes me is that in the real world, you see very similar patterns unfold. Now, we've studied the psychology of wealth for now more than 20 years.
我谈到了想要模拟现实世界的某些方面。人们可能会吹毛求疵。我的意思是，也许这就像伪装成科学的寓言，或者伪装成寓言的科学。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，这项研究存在问题。但我认为让我印象深刻的一点是，在现实世界中，你会看到非常相似的模式展开。现在，我们研究财富心理学已经超过 20 年了。
People have studied the experience of other forms of privilege. or other forms of status. And one of the uniform insights across all of that research is that the higher in status you are, and we find the higher in wealth you are, the more wealth you have, the more entitled and the more deserving of that privilege you feel. And you could say, well, of course, like if you've earned your money, then of course you deserve that money, right? Because it's come to you through your own hard effort.
人们研究过其他形式特权或地位的体验。所有这些研究中一个统一的见解是，你的地位越高，我们发现你的财富越高，你拥有的财富越多，你就越感到有权获得这种特权，也越觉得理所应当。你可以说，好吧，当然，如果你赚了钱，那么你当然应该得到那笔钱，对吧？因为它是通过你自己的努力得来的。
But we've studied this among lots and lots and lots of people, including people who inherited wealth and college students who have done nothing to earn their own wealth. And you actually find that among wealthy college students, high class college students, levels of entitlement in deservingness that exceed that of their parents. So college students who are wealthy have done very little to deserve that. They've been born into their privilege in many, or much like the monopoly players were just sort of randomly flipped into their positions of privilege. And yet, they feel deserving and entitled to more than others in life. So I think that's an interesting, I think, and what the monopoly experiment gives us is it's sort of an interesting insight into how
但我们在很多人身上研究过这一点，包括继承了财富的人和没有做任何事情来赚取自己财富的大学生。你实际上发现，在富有的大学生、高阶层大学生中，权利感和理所应当的程度超过了他们的父母。所以富有的大学生几乎没有做什么来应得这些。他们出生在特权中，就像“大富翁”玩家一样，只是被随机掷硬币掷到了特权位置。然而，他们觉得自己在生活中比别人更应得，更有权利。所以我认为这很有趣，我认为“大富翁”实验给我们提供了一个有趣的见解，即
the human mind makes sense of the privileges that a person experiences and attributes those privileges in part to one's own deservingness, one's own merit, as opposed to the luck and the features of the world that through no effort of our own got us into that. position of luck in the first place. I knew some of those people in college. I know what you're talking about. We all did. Did you find gender differences? I'm just curious if women behave the same way as men. And did you pit women against men? And what were the dynamics there? Yeah. So that's a great question. I think I would have designed the study a little differently to have been able to figure out if there are really reliable gender effects. So we had men playing against women, women playing against women. So we had
人类思维如何理解一个人所经历的特权，并将这些特权部分归因于自己的应得、自己的功绩，而不是归因于运气和世界的特征，这些特征在没有任何努力的情况下让我们处于那种幸运的位置。我在大学里认识一些这样的人。我知道你在说什么。我们都认识。你发现性别差异了吗？我只是好奇女性的行为是否与男性相同。你让女性与男性对抗了吗？那里的动态是什么？是的。这是一个很好的问题。我想如果我能设计出不同的研究，就能弄清楚是否存在真正可靠的性别影响。所以我们有男性与女性对战，女性与女性对战。所以我们有
we had all all versions crossed we didn't find um major sex differences in this study though i would say generally um across the studies that we've run uh upwards of maybe let's say 40 to 50 studies at this point looking at broad patterns in social orientation uh social tendencies uh prosociality unethicality, narcissism, entitlement. Typically speaking, men, at least North American men tend to score higher in these various, you might say, self-focused or self-regarding tendencies. So men are more competitive, generally speaking. We're not talking major effects. And of course, I'm talking about patterns across thousands of people. So there's obviously lots of exceptions to the rules. But generally speaking, the pattern is men are typically more competitive, a little more entitled,
我们有所有交叉的版本。我们没有在研究中发现主要的性别差异，尽管我想说，总的来说，在我们目前进行的超过 40 到 50 项研究中，观察社会取向、社会倾向、亲社会性、不道德性、自恋、权利感等广泛模式。通常来说，男性，至少是北美男性，往往在这些你可能称之为自我关注或自我导向的倾向中得分更高。所以男性通常更具竞争性。我们谈论的不是重大的影响。当然，我谈论的是成千上万人的模式。所以规则显然有很多例外。但总的来说，模式是男性通常更具竞争性，更有权利感，
to feel a little more special, a little less oriented to the well-being of other people. And there's lots of meta-analyses that suggest similar differences, whether they're biological or socialized, but that women in different ways and sometimes in very small ways, but seem to be a little more empathetic, a little more compassionate, and a little more oriented to the well-being of others. You did another really interesting study regarding cars and how people acted depending on which type of car they were driving. Can you talk about that a little bit? I started out in this world as a person really interested in moral psychology, the psychology of pro-sociality. What are the factors that drive human kindness and cooperation and that get people
感觉自己更特别，对他人福祉的关注度稍低。有很多荟萃分析表明存在类似的差异，无论是生物学上的还是社会化的，但女性在不同方面，有时以非常微小的方式，似乎更具同理心，更富有同情心，更关注他人的福祉。你还做了另一项关于汽车以及人们如何根据他们驾驶的汽车类型采取行动的非常有趣的研究。你能谈谈那个吗？我最初进入这个领域时，是一个对道德心理学、亲社会心理学非常感兴趣的人。是什么因素驱动了人类的善良和合作，并让人们
to get outside themselves and want to do nice things for other people or behave in collective action with their groups. And so when we started working on this research in social class, there was a lot of low-hanging fruit. And so we'd done some studies finding, for example, that in interpersonal interactions, wealthier people are actually a little less generous, a little less compassionate. And we followed that up with a set of studies looking at individual differences as a result of social class in how willing people were to break certain normative rules of conduct or what we would say engage in ethical violations, little things. Like you pay for a coffee and a muffin at a coffee shop for $10 and you're given change as if you paid for 20.
走出自我，想要为他人做善事，或者与他们的群体进行集体行动。所以当我们开始研究社会阶层时，有很多唾手可得的成果。所以我们做了一些研究，发现例如，在人际互动中，较富有的人实际上稍微不那么慷慨，稍微不那么富有同情心。我们随后进行了一系列研究，观察社会阶层导致的个体差异，即人们在多大程度上愿意打破某些规范的行为规则，或者我们所说的从事道德违规，一些小事。比如你在咖啡店花 10 美元买了一杯咖啡和一个松饼，而你得到的找零却好像你付了 20 美元。
How likely would you be to keep that extra change, you know? And I think that these kinds of things are tradeoffs and conflicts that we navigate daily. You know, if you're stuck in traffic, you're thinking about, should I zip ahead? of this other car or should I wait my turn in line. You know, we're always like thinking about the extent to which we should prioritize our own welfare versus the well-being of others and what's the right thing versus the thing that I want to do. And we're constantly juggling these things.
你有多大可能保留那笔额外的找零，你知道吗？我认为这些事情是我们每天都要应对的权衡和冲突。你知道，如果你被困在交通中，你会考虑，我应该抢在另一辆车前面，还是应该在队伍中等待轮到我。你知道，我们总是像在思考我们应该在多大程度上优先考虑我们自己的福利，而不是他人的福祉，什么是正确的事情，什么是我想做的事情。我们一直在权衡这些事情。
And so we'd run a bunch of studies finding that generally speaking, surprising to us at the time, wealthier individuals were actually more likely to not only endorse unethicality, but to also engage in small little acts of cheating and normative violations to prioritize their own welfare of the welfare of other people. And I remember at the time thinking like, okay, if, you know, definitely if we publish these results, people are going to be really surprised. And one of the questions is going to be, I mean, because in many ways it's kind of counter-stereotypical, right? Like, why would wealthy people seem? You know, they've got more to begin with. So could we find ways to look at this in the real world?
所以我们进行了一系列研究，发现总的来说，当时让我们感到惊讶的是，较富有的人实际上不仅更有可能认可不道德行为，而且更有可能从事小的作弊行为和规范违规，以优先考虑自己的福利而不是他人的福利。我记得当时想，好吧，如果，你知道，如果我们发表这些结果，人们肯定会非常惊讶。其中一个问题将是，我的意思是，因为在很多方面这有点反刻板印象，对吧？比如，为什么富人会看起来？你知道，他们一开始就拥有更多。所以我们能找到在现实世界中观察这一点的方法吗？
How could we do this? And so my collaborators and I at the time were talking about all sorts of different ways to do this. And I was heading on my way to a meeting and I was waiting at a crosswalk. And I was kind of like thinking about these different study versions that we'd come up with. And I'm standing at the crosswalk and cars are just zipping by me. No one's stopping. And I remember thinking to myself, well, this is interesting. I could do a study like this where we look at whether drivers abide by the law.
我们怎么能做到这一点？所以我和我的合作者当时正在讨论各种不同的方法。我正要去开会，在人行横道等候。我当时在想我们想出的这些不同的研究版本。我站在人行横道上，汽车从我身边呼啸而过。没有人停下来。我记得我对自己说，嗯，这很有趣。我可以做一个这样的研究，看看司机是否遵守法律。
And in California, just as an example, it's the law to stop for a pedestrian who's waiting to cross. And so we put together a team and we ran a series of studies that looked at whether drivers are different kinds of cars, which is our way of modeling wealth and status in the real world. What kind of car do you drive? Of course, it's the case that people without some means might drive fancy cars, but generally speaking, the correlation between the car that you drive and how much wealth you have is very, very high. We piloted that and we found that the correlation was around 0.7 or 0.8, which is double the
在加州，作为一个例子，法律规定要为等待过马路的行人停车。所以我们组建了一个团队，进行了一系列研究，观察不同类型汽车的司机，这是我们模拟现实世界中财富和地位的方式。你开什么车？当然，没有一定经济能力的人也可能开豪车，但总的来说，你开的车和你拥有的财富之间的相关性非常非常高。我们对此进行了试点，发现相关性在 0.7 或 0.8 左右，这是
correlation between how educated you are and how much money you make. So it's actually a very reliable indicator of your wealth. And so we looked at whether drivers of more or less expensive cars would be more or less inclined to do things that violate California vehicle code. So we ran one study at a four-way intersection and another study at a crosswalk where we, in that study, had a pedestrian walk up to the crosswalk. A car is coming down the road.
你的受教育程度和你赚多少钱之间相关性的两倍。所以它实际上是你财富的一个非常可靠的指标。所以我们观察了驾驶较昂贵或较便宜汽车的司机是否会更多或更少地倾向于做违反加州车辆法规的事情。所以我们在一个四向交叉路口进行了一项研究，在另一个人行横道进行了另一项研究，在那项研究中，我们让一名行人走到人行横道。一辆车正沿着路开过来。
The pedestrian would always look to the driver and nod signaling their intent to cross. And then outside of view, we had coders hiding behind bushes, coding the expensiveness of a vehicle as it comes down the roadway, and whether or not the vehicle then stops for our pedestrian who's signaled his or her or their intent to cross. We did this for hundreds of different vehicles, and what we found was this kind of clear, linear trend, even controlling for lots of other things. The more expensive your car was, the more likely you were to break the law, in this case,
行人总是会看着司机并点头示意他们过马路的意图。然后在视线之外，我们有编码员躲在灌木丛后面，对沿着道路行驶的车辆的昂贵程度进行编码，以及车辆是否为示意过马路意图的行人停车。我们对数百辆不同的车辆进行了这项研究，我们发现了一种清晰的线性趋势，即使控制了许多其他因素。你的车越贵，你就越有可能违法，在这种情况下，
by driving right through the crosswalk and not stopping. And I remember at the time, like being surprised by this. And also when we published the results, I got lots of lots and lots of emails from drivers of different kinds of cars. For example, Prius drivers saying like, yeah, okay, okay, okay. Actually, Prius drivers at the time, they scored relatively high in our expensiveness category because Prius cars were at the time,
直接穿过人行横道而不停车。我记得当时，对此感到惊讶。而且当我们发表结果时，我收到了许多许多来自不同类型汽车司机的电子邮件。例如，普锐斯司机说，是的，好吧，好吧，好吧。实际上，普锐斯司机当时在我们的昂贵类别中得分相对较高，因为普锐斯汽车在当时，
some of the more expensive cars that you could drive. And they were also Prius drivers somehow, I don't know that these would hold up nowadays, but then they were among our most likely to be breaking the law. They would drive right through the crosswalk. And I got a lot of emails from Prius drivers saying, well, we're too busy, we're too focused on, you know, the efficiency of our mileage, right?
是你可能驾驶的最昂贵的汽车之一。而且他们也是普锐斯司机，不知何故，我不知道这些在今天是否还成立，但当时他们是我们最有可能违法的人群之一。他们会直接穿过人行横道。我收到了很多来自普锐斯司机的电子邮件，说，好吧，我们太忙了，我们太专注于，你知道，我们里程的效率，对吧？
And I know that, like, I got emails explaining that breaking, for a pedestrian would implicate the climate because it would mean that your gas efficiency would go down, your mileage per gallon would go down. And so they're making an executive decision to better the environment as opposed to stopping for someone else. Anyway, all of which is to say, I think there are lots of reasons why someone might stop or might not. I think generally speaking, what these studies showcase is that maybe in very small ways, your levels of privilege, your life style as signaled and expressed through the class environment that you inhabit is reflected in these little ways in which you might, in these split-second decisions,
我知道，我收到了解释说，为行人停车会影响气候，因为这意味着你的燃油效率会下降，每加仑英里数会下降。所以他们做出了一个行政决定，为了改善环境，而不是为别人停车。总之，所有这些都是说，我认为一个人可能会停车或可能不会停车有很多原因。我认为总的来说，这些研究展示的是，也许在非常微小的方式上，你的特权水平，你通过你所居住的阶层环境所表现和表达的生活方式，反映在这些小事上，在这些瞬间的决定中，
think about whether what you need to do is more important than what someone else needs in a given situation. And we find at least that in those kinds of little decisions, it's the case that the wealthier you are, the more likely you are in various ways to prioritize your own needs, your own goals, your own desires, your own interests above the interests of other people. What about people who were, they weren't born into wealth, but they earned vast wealth? I mean, does that affect people's behavior differently depending on how their money was acquired? Yeah, it's a really important question, Kim. And it's one that we have some scientific answers to, but I think that work is only just beginning. I mean, intuitively, I would say, of course it matters. How you gained your wealth, of course it matters for how you experience it. But I think the effects,
思考你所需要做的事情是否比别人在特定情况下所需要的更重要。我们至少发现，在那些小决定中，确实是你的财富越多，你就越有可能以各种方式优先考虑你自己的需求、你自己的目标、你自己的欲望、你自己的利益，高于他人的利益。那么那些不是出生在财富中，而是赚取了巨额财富的人呢？我的意思是，这是否会根据他们的钱是如何获得的而对人们的行为产生不同的影响？是的，这是一个非常重要的问题，金。这是我们有一些科学答案的问题，但我认为这项工作才刚刚开始。我的意思是，直觉上，我会说，这当然很重要。你如何获得财富，当然对你如何体验它很重要。但我认为这些影响，
in some cases, are kind of surprising. So we ran a study just a couple of years ago looking at people born into wealth versus in comparing them to people who became wealthy over their lifetimes. And the specific question we were interested in here is who of those two groups, people born rich or people who have become rich, but who started out less well off, are more sympathetic and empathetic to others, more likely to be willing to support various measures to help others in need. And when thinking about that question, you could generate one idea, which would be that, yeah, someone who's been less well off. Let's say someone who's been poor. Well, they've experienced what poverty is like. They've experienced what immediate need is like. They've experienced structural unfairness or injustice in their environment.
在某些情况下，有点令人惊讶。所以我们几年前进行了一项研究，观察出生在财富中的人与一生中变得富有的人进行比较。我们在这里感兴趣的具体问题是，这两组人中，出生时富有的人或变得富有但起步时不太富裕的人，谁对他人更具同情心和同理心，更有可能愿意支持各种帮助他人度过难关的措施。在思考这个问题时，你可以产生一个想法，那就是，是的，一个不太富裕的人。假设一个曾经贫穷的人。好吧，他们经历过贫困是什么样子。他们经历过迫切的需求是什么样子。他们经历过环境中的结构性不公平或不公正。
They know what it's like to be poor. And so even though they're rich now, maybe because of that increased experience and increased exposure and increased empathy, they're more sympathetic to the plight of others, to the plight of the unfortunate ones. And so I'm more willing to offer up help to help others out. actually we found the opposite. So when comparing people who born into privilege versus people who became wealthy, it's people who were born into wealth that were actually more sympathetic and more empathetic because those that had earned their wealth had a certain story they could tell. And the story that they could tell was one of deservingness. And it was that I know that I,
他们知道贫穷是什么样子。所以即使他们现在很富有，也许因为那种增加的经验、增加的接触和增加的同理心，他们对其他人的困境、不幸者的困境更具同情心。所以更愿意提供帮助来帮助别人。实际上我们发现了相反的情况。所以当比较出生在特权中的人与变得富有的人时，实际上是出生在财富中的人更具同情心和同理心，因为那些赚取财富的人有一个他们可以讲述的故事。他们可以讲述的故事是关于应得的故事。那就是我知道我，
because I experienced upward mobility, I know it's possible to be upwardly mobile. So I feel deserving of that wealth that I now have. And so if you're not equally wealthier, if you're in need, because I know that it's possible to have made it and pulled yourself up by your own bootstraps, it's your fault that you haven't been able to do that at least yet. And so that story allows room for blaming others for their own misfortunes as opposed to giving rise to willingness to help them. So I think that the effects are probably complicated. There's other work that looks at differences in entitlement and narcissism as a function of
因为我经历了向上流动，我知道向上流动是可能的。所以我感到我理应获得我现在拥有的财富。所以如果你没有同样富有，如果你有需要，因为我知道通过自己的努力是可以成功的，那么你没能做到这一点至少是你的错。所以那个故事为指责他人自己的不幸留下了空间，而不是产生帮助他们的意愿。所以我认为这些影响可能很复杂。还有其他工作观察权利感和自恋的差异，作为
how you came about your well, finding intriguing differences there. I don't need to go into that, but generally speaking, I think it matters and the work is just now starting to get off the ground. Do you know, do findings like these hold across countries and cultures, especially countries that are more collectivist versus individualistic? Yeah, I think it's a really important question. I should have prefaced regarding our findings that they're primarily in what some might refer to as weird cultures, Western, educated, industrialized, rich, democratic. Anyway, most of them are done with North American or certainly Western participants. And I think there's a lot of reason to think that the effects of social class and of wealth and status might vary depending on your geographic location. But I think
你如何获得财富的函数，在那里发现了有趣的差异。我不需要深入探讨那个，但总的来说，我认为这很重要，这项工作才刚刚开始。你知道，像这样的发现是否适用于不同的国家和文化，特别是那些更集体主义而不是个人主义的国家？是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。我应该在关于我们的发现之前说明，它们主要是在某些人可能称之为 WEIRD 文化中，即西方、受过教育、工业化、富有、民主。无论如何，它们大多数是与北美或当然是西方参与者一起完成的。我认为有很多理由认为社会阶层、财富和地位的影响可能会根据你的地理位置而变化。但我认为
importantly, vary as a function of your culture. And so there's work that's shown, for example, done by by Wang and Mernigan, Keith Mernigan a few years ago that shows that across lots of different countries, the association between, say, wealth and the endorsement of unethicality seems to be culturally, if not universal, certainly culturally consistent. So they look at it, and I think upwards of 20 different countries and find similar effects, the wealthier you are, the more likely you are to say that it's okay to do small unethical acts in the favor of your own self-interest. Now, those effects, while they seem consistent, I think, are likely to vary as a function of where you are, what the values are around the social safety net and around wealth.
重要的是，作为你文化的函数而变化。所以有一些工作表明，例如，王和默尼根，基思·默尼根几年前所做的工作表明，在许多不同的国家，财富与不道德行为的认可之间的关联，如果不是普遍的，至少在文化上是一致的。所以他们观察它，我认为在 20 多个不同的国家，发现了类似的影响，你越富有，你就越有可能说为了自己的利益做一些小的不道德行为是可以的。现在，这些影响，虽然它们看起来是一致的，但我认为，很可能会根据你在哪里，围绕社会安全网和财富的价值观是什么而变化。
In the U.S., we have the, whether it's unfortunate or not, we have a culture that sort of prioritizes almost excessive pursuits of self-interest. You know, competitiveness and meritocracy is a, you might say, almost a sacred value. And so if that's the case, then that's going to legitimize wealth and wealth inequalities in a way that more typically socially progressive or liberal countries might not, where there's a stronger, say, explicit value toward noblese-obledge and the responsibility of sharing what you have with others, for instance, via progressive taxation. Anyway, that's a long way of saying, I think it matters, and we don't really have a lot of data yet that sort of unpacks where and why. We're going to take a short break, and when we return, we'll ask Dr. Piff whether money can buy happiness.
在美国，我们有，无论它是否不幸，我们有一种文化，它优先考虑几乎过度的自身利益追求。你知道，竞争和精英管理是一个，你可能说是，几乎神圣的价值观。所以如果是这样的话，那么这将以一种更典型的社会进步或自由国家可能不会的方式使财富和财富不平等合法化，在那些国家，有一种更强的，比如说，对贵族义务的明确价值观，以及与他人分享你所拥有的责任，例如通过累进税。无论如何，这说了一大堆，我认为这很重要，我们还没有很多数据来解析在哪里以及为什么。我们将进行短暂的休息，当我们回来时，我们将询问皮夫博士金钱是否能买到幸福。
Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new, while the rest of it looks, well, not so new? It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from all the time. best of all we can install it for you starting at only 49 cents per square foot so all you have to do is pick your perfect floor start your carpet project today at the home depot how doers get more done exclusions apply for licenses see homedepro.com slash license numbers you said this place was steps from the water we just haven't found the steps yet how much did we save enough enough to get lost or you could book a stay with Hilton Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你有没有重新布置过家具，发现下面的地毯看起来像新的一样，而其余的部分看起来，嗯，没那么新？是时候升级地毯了。在家得宝，我们有时尚的选择，价格简单，一直都有。最棒的是，我们可以为你安装，每平方英尺仅需 49 美分起，所以你所要做的就是选择你完美的地板，今天就开始你的地毯项目吧，在家得宝，实干家如何完成更多工作，排除条款适用，许可证请参阅 homedepot.com/license-numbers，你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥，我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？足够了，足够去迷路了，或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿，欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边只有几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for this day. There's been psychological research into the amount of money it takes to reach happiness. And there was one study, at least one study, maybe several, that found that there was, at $70,000 people's happiness kind of plateaus. And after that, you don't get hugely happier after
希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可节省 20%，获得你预期的住宿。当你想要节省，而不是惊喜时。你住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了这次住宿。已经有心理学研究探讨了达到幸福所需的金钱数量。至少有一项研究，也许几项，发现，在 7 万美元时，人们的幸福感趋于平稳。在那之后，你不会因为
making more money. I'm just wondering, does having more money make people happier? That's a question that moral philosophers and poets and artists and people have thought about, not just about money, but about resources for as long as we've had them. So these are long-standing questions. And there are questions that we have some answers to, but I think the work is ongoing. There's new work that suggests that maybe, in fact, the plateau isn't at $70,000, but it's much later. And as your money goes up, happiness does, but the incremental value of each sort of rise in income starts to diminish.
赚更多的钱而变得非常快乐。我只是想知道，拥有更多的钱会让人们更快乐吗？这是一个道德哲学家、诗人和艺术家以及人们只要拥有资源就一直在思考的问题，不仅仅是关于金钱，而是关于资源。所以这些是长期存在的问题。这些是我们有一些答案的问题，但我认为工作正在进行中。有新的工作表明，也许，事实上，平稳期不是在 7 万美元，而是在更晚的时候。随着你的钱增加，幸福感也会增加，但每种收入增长的增量价值开始减少。
So it's almost logarithmic. So to an extent, money research tells us, buys you some version of happiness, not as much as people think it does, and that effect seems to diminish as money goes up. But I think what's more important is that what we're also simultaneously learning, and I'm just going to mention two different things here is to the extent that money buys you happiness, what's almost more important is how you spend the money. And we know that work, there's a lot of work that tells us that spending money on others, for instance, versus spending it on yourself, buys you a lot more happiness, a lot more bang for your buck and has a much larger effect on well-being. When it comes to how to spend resources, using your money to buy yourself time, for example, has a much bigger effect on happiness than does using your money to, say, buy yourself material things, buying yourself experiences over material goods as a better predictor of happiness.
所以它几乎是对数的。因此，在一定程度上，金钱研究告诉我们，能买到某种版本的幸福，没有人们想象的那么多，而且这种影响似乎随着金钱的增加而减少。但我认为更重要的是，我们同时也在学习，我在这里只提两件事，即在金钱能买到幸福的程度上，几乎更重要的是你如何花钱。我们知道这项工作，有很多工作告诉我们，把钱花在别人身上，例如，而不是花在自己身上，能买到更多的幸福，你的钱能发挥更大的作用，对幸福感有更大的影响。当谈到如何花费资源时，用你的钱为自己买时间，例如，对幸福的影响比用你的钱，比如说，买物质东西要大得多，为自己购买体验而不是物质商品是幸福的更好预测指标。
What we find, actually, is that happiness, when you break it down, happiness is like a very complicated psychological phenomenon, right? It's, you can think of it as a simple word, are you happy or not? But in fact, when you study it, you know, what does it even mean to people? If you ask someone, are you happy right now? Some people might say, well, it depends on what you mean. I feel content. I wouldn't necessarily say I'm happy. So happiness is a very multifaceted construct. And psychologists have been grappling with what kind of multifaceted construct it is. One of the things that we've been finding, and I think that this has, you know, been true over the last, say, 20 years as people have been thinking about the role of emotions in happiness is that happiness is actually kind of a, you might say, a gestalt state
我们发现，实际上，幸福，当你把它分解时，幸福就像一个非常复杂的心理现象，对吧？它，你可以把它想成一个简单的词，你快乐吗？但事实上，当你研究它时，你知道，它对人们意味着什么？如果你问某人，你现在快乐吗？有些人可能会说，嗯，这取决于你的意思。我感到满足。我不一定会说我很快乐。所以幸福是一个非常多方面的结构。心理学家一直在努力解决它是什么样的多方面结构。我们一直在发现的一件事，我认为这在过去，比如说，20 年里，当人们一直在思考情绪在幸福中的作用时，这是真实的，那就是幸福实际上是一种，你可能说是，一种格式塔状态
derived from our experiences of not just one emotion, but lots of different kinds of positive and maybe even negative emotions. And so when we break happiness down, as we did in one study, into its composite emotions and look at people's tendencies to experience different kinds of positive emotions, all of which contribute to this overall state of happiness, we actually find this really interesting pattern where the wealthier you are, the more likely you are to experience certain kinds of positive emotions like pride, but the less likely you are to experience other kinds of positive emotions like love, like compassion, like awe, that are equally, or you might even say in some cases, more powerfully connected to happiness.
源于我们对不仅仅是一种情绪，而是许多不同种类的积极甚至可能是消极情绪的体验。所以当我们把幸福分解时，正如我们在一项研究中所做的那样，分解成它的复合情绪，并观察人们体验不同种类积极情绪的倾向，所有这些都促成了这种整体的幸福状态，我们实际上发现了这个非常有趣的模式，即你越富有，你就越有可能体验到某些种类的积极情绪，比如骄傲，但你越不可能体验到其他种类的积极情绪，比如爱，比如同情，比如敬畏，它们同样，或者你甚至可以在某些情况下说，更强有力地与幸福相连。
So I think wealth and happiness are connected, but the ways in which wealth-connected to happiness is pretty complicated. And actually, it seems like wealth might buy you certain kinds of happiness, but not all of them. It's not an unmitigated, unequivocal good. You know, I've not found this in my life because I'm not necessarily wealthy, but people have reached out with their stories of wealth as, you know, our lab and the work that we publish has gotten some traction. And they tell me stories of like kind of retrospectively looking back at their lives and feeling like, you know, they had spent a lot of time. as their money aggregated, as they gained more wealth, as they gained more status.
所以我认为财富和幸福是相连的，但财富与幸福相连的方式相当复杂。而且实际上，看起来财富可能会为你买到某种幸福，但不是全部。它不是一种毫无保留、毫无疑问的好事。你知道，我在我的生活中没有发现这一点，因为我不一定富有，但人们在我们的实验室和我们发表的工作获得了一些关注时，带着他们的财富故事联系了我。他们告诉我回顾他们生活的故事，感觉好像，你知道，他们花了很多时间。随着他们的钱积累，随着他们获得更多财富，随着他们获得更多地位。
They got more involved in their career, more focused on their numbers, more focused on working weekends and hours, and they lost sight of the things that in retrospect they wish they hadn't, like their friends, their social relationships, their family, they wish they'd spent their time differently. And so I think wealth and money kind of shape your value system into a particular set or constellation of things that gets you to focus and prioritize on some things in life, but perhaps lose sight of some others like your social relationships, your inherent connection to other people around you and the ways in which you can derive value from those connections. And losing sight of those
他们更多地参与到他们的职业中，更专注于他们的数字，更专注于在周末和加班工作，他们忽视了他们回顾时希望没有忽视的事情，比如他们的朋友、他们的社会关系、他们的家人，他们希望他们能以不同的方式度过他们的时间。所以我认为财富和金钱把你的价值体系塑造成一组特定的东西，让你专注于生活中的某些事情，但也许忽视了其他一些事情，比如你的社会关系，你与周围其他人的内在联系，以及你可以从这些联系中获得价值的方式。而忽视这些
things are, I think, major determinants of your well-being and have a negative impact on it. Let's talk for a minute about politics, just in a general sense. I'm wondering how wealth affects people's political attitudes. You know, there's a long history in this country of the well-off favoring the Republican Party and being more conservative in their values while the Democratic Party seems to be in touch with more average adults. Do the rich tend to be Republican and conservative, or is that just a stereotype? I think it's largely a stereotype. You've got wealth on both sides and lots of wealth on both sides.
事情，我认为，是你幸福的主要决定因素，并对它产生负面影响。让我们谈谈政治，以一种普遍的意义。我想知道财富如何影响人们的政治态度。你知道，在这个国家，富人倾向于共和党并在价值观上更保守，而民主党似乎与更多的普通成年人有联系，这有很长的历史。富人倾向于共和党和保守派吗，还是那只是一个刻板印象？我认为这在很大程度上是一个刻板印象。你在双方都有财富，而且双方都有大量的财富。
generally speaking, the work that looks at wealth and your political attitudes finds that at least economically speaking, the wealthier you are, the more likely you are to be, let's say, economically conservative. And what I mean by that is, if you're wealthy, you're less likely to support something like progressive taxation, you're less likely to support redistribution in other ways, you're less likely to support redistribution in other ways, you're less likely to support, a social safety net that offers, let's say, universal health care or universal basic income. And you're more likely to endorse attitudes and values, politicians, and political policies that you might say protect the wealthy against taxation and that help conserve privilege. These aren't massive effects. There are lots of different things that drive political attitudes. but it basically, I think a lot of this seems to stem from, well, if you have resources, then you're going to feel motivated to protect them.
总的来说，研究财富与政治态度的相关性发现，至少在经济层面上，你越富有，就越有可能在经济上持保守态度。我的意思是，如果你很富有，你就不太可能支持累进税制，不太可能支持其他形式的财富再分配，也不太可能支持提供全民医保或全民基本收入等社会保障体系。你更有可能认同那些保护富人免受税收影响、有助于维护特权的价值观、政治人物和政策。这些影响并非巨大，毕竟驱动政治态度的因素有很多。但我认为，这很大程度上源于：如果你拥有资源，你就会有保护它们的动力。
You're going to want to maintain them. You feel deserving of them. And so those kinds of attitudes tend to be more at least typically associated with conservative economic policies. There's even work that suggests that, you know, because you could, you can make lots of different kinds of arguments for why that relationship might exist in the first place. There's all sorts of chicken and egg stuff that you could talk about. There's work that finds, this is with Hasi Brown Ionutsi, who's at the University of Virginia. She manipulates levels of wealth within even games and finds that if you experience privilege and status within a game, you become economically
你会想要维持现状，并觉得这些财富是你应得的。因此，这些态度通常与保守的经济政策相关联。甚至有研究表明，你可以为这种关系的存在提出各种各样的论点。关于“先有鸡还是先有蛋”的问题，有很多可以探讨的地方。弗吉尼亚大学的 Hasi Brown Ionutsi 的研究发现，即使在游戏中，她通过操纵财富水平，发现如果你在游戏中体验到特权和地位，你在经济上就会变得
speaking more conservative by being less willing to support redistribution within the game. I think it's just a general tendency among elites to want to do things that could, serve their power and privilege. I don't think that's only true of elites. I think that's true of anyone who's in a position of power, of high status, or of privilege, that they will feel motivated to defend the status quo, because after all, they're benefactors of it. There are, of course, exceptions to that, but I think generally speaking, the better off you are, the more motivated you are to keep the world as it is because you're benefiting from it. I mentioned in the introduction, the rise and income inequality being a huge issue in our nation, probably in the world right now.
更加保守，因为你不太愿意支持游戏内的财富再分配。我认为精英阶层有一种普遍倾向，即想要做一些能够维护其权力和特权的事情。我不认为这只适用于精英，我认为任何处于权力、高地位或特权地位的人，都会有捍卫现状的动力，因为毕竟他们是现状的受益者。当然也有例外，但总的来说，你的境况越好，你就越有动力维持现状，因为你从中受益。我在引言中提到，收入不平等的加剧是我们国家，甚至可能是当今世界的一个巨大问题。
How do you see these psychological effects that you've been studying playing out on a more global societal scale in terms of how we think about and deal with inequality and poverty? First of all, I'm certainly one voice among many, many, many that have talked about the very pernicious problematic effects that inequality can have on societies. And I think it's not a stretch to say that many of the issues that we face as a nation, as a species, as a planet, you could say derive in part from the extreme levels of inequality that we're being experienced. You know, you can even attribute something like the severe polarization that we're experiencing in the U.S. right now as resulting, at least in part, from the vast economic inequality that our population's experiencing. So I think inequality is problematic for lots of reasons, in part because it makes it so difficult, because it's so polarizing, to come together as cohesive units to collectively confront issues we're
你如何看待你所研究的这些心理效应在全球社会层面上的表现，特别是在我们如何思考和处理不平等与贫困问题方面？首先，我当然只是众多讨论不平等对社会造成的极其有害和棘手影响的声音之一。我认为，说我们作为一个国家、一个物种、一个星球所面临的许多问题，部分源于我们正在经历的极端不平等，这并不夸张。你知道，甚至可以说，我们目前在美国经历的严重两极分化，至少部分源于我们人口所经历的巨大经济不平等。所以我认为不平等在很多方面都是个问题，部分原因在于它造成了极大的两极分化，使得我们很难团结一致地共同面对我们
facing. So I think that our work is, you know, lends a little bit of insight into the idea that inequality is problematic and given that we're finding that the more wealth you have, the more motivated you are to conserve that wealth, to not want to share it with others, and to even be willing to do things that break the rules to get more wealth. There's no reason to think that inequality on an individual level would necessarily change, that people would all of a sudden say, like, look, I've got enough, let me now start sharing it with others. There doesn't seem to be that you know, mental switch. The more wealth you have, the more willing you are to do things to aggregate it, to conserve it, to conserve that privilege for yourself. And so you can expect,
所面临的问题。因此，我认为我们的工作提供了一些见解，即不平等是有问题的。鉴于我们发现你拥有的财富越多，你保护这些财富、不愿与他人分享的动力就越强，甚至愿意为了获得更多财富而打破规则。没有理由认为不平等在个人层面上会自然改变，人们不会突然说：“看，我已经有足够的了，让我开始与他人分享吧。”似乎不存在那种心理开关。你拥有的财富越多，你就越愿意做些事情来积累它、保护它，为自己保留这种特权。所以你可以预见，
based on that, that inequality just gives rise to more inequality, which in turn gives rise to more inequality, you get something like runaway inequality that just kind of exacerbates differences between those that have and those that don't over time. Lots of people have talked about trickle-down benefits of wealth. That's part of the foundation. insights of even capitalism in our country, that if you let capitalism kind of run wild, then the market always corrects itself in part by having those at the top sort of use their resources to benefit everyone, building jobs, building out different systems toward efficiency that help not just them, but everyone within the population, you kind of carry people along with you.
基于此，不平等只会导致更多的不平等，进而导致更多的不平等，你会得到一种类似失控的不平等，随着时间的推移，这只会加剧富人和穷人之间的差距。许多人谈论过财富的“涓滴效应”。这也是我们国家资本主义的核心见解之一，即如果你让资本主义自由发展，市场总是会自我修正，部分方式是让顶层的人利用他们的资源造福所有人，创造就业机会，建立各种提高效率的系统，这不仅帮助了他们自己，也帮助了人口中的每个人，从而带动了其他人。
We've seen politically, socially, that does not seem to be the case. Maybe trickle-down economics is a real thing, but trickle down compassion doesn't seem to be. Now, there is a move afoot among some of these billionaires, our oligarchs in this country, to give their money away, to pledge to give their money away. And is that coming out of a sense of guilt and pressure from others, I mean, or people suddenly becoming more empathetic? It's hard to say because I know, for instance,
但在政治和社会层面，我们看到情况似乎并非如此。也许“涓滴经济学”是真实存在的，但“涓滴同情心”似乎并不存在。现在，我们国家的一些亿万富翁，也就是我们的寡头，正在采取行动捐出他们的钱，承诺捐出他们的财富。这是出于内疚感和来自他人的压力，还是人们突然变得更有同理心了？这很难说，因为我知道，例如，
like the initiatives like the giving pledge, which are really interesting. and actually we're doing a bunch of studies on them. I don't know what's individually motivating each of the members of the giving pledge, and these are billionaires who have pledged upwards of 50% of their fortunes to different charitable causes. I think it's a wonderful endeavor. I don't know what's specifically motivating them. There are lots of different motivations, including some tax benefits.
像“捐赠誓言”这样的倡议非常有趣，我们实际上正在对它们进行一系列研究。我不知道是什么在激励“捐赠誓言”的每一位成员，这些亿万富翁承诺将他们 50% 以上的财富捐给不同的慈善事业。我认为这是一项了不起的努力。我不知道具体是什么在激励他们。有很多不同的动机，包括一些税收优惠。
Certainly, they're doing it in public ways, right? So the moment you're giving away charity in a way that's being actively recognized by people, there's a lot of interesting benefits that you get as a result, including billionaires get to hold on to billions. And just by virtue of having given some of those billions away, they are now treated as moral and good people, you know, even though they have exorbitant levels of wealth. I'm not saying that the giving pledge is a problem, but I think that the motivations for people to become members of those kinds of initiatives can be multifaceted and not necessarily pro-social. There's a lot of work that suggests that actually the charity of the wealthy is often oriented toward causes that actually conserve and exacerbate inequality as opposed to mitigate it. So wealthy people are more likely to give to alma maters. They're more likely to give to different kinds of initiatives, even cultural institutions that play into elites that help conserve the power of upper class.
当然，他们是以公开的方式进行的，对吧？所以当你以一种被人们积极认可的方式进行慈善捐赠时，你会因此获得很多有趣的利益，包括亿万富翁可以保留数十亿资产。仅仅因为捐出了一部分财富，他们现在就被视为道德高尚的人，尽管他们拥有极其庞大的财富。我并不是说“捐赠誓言”有问题，但我认为人们成为这类倡议成员的动机可能是多方面的，而不一定是亲社会的。有很多研究表明，富人的慈善事业往往倾向于那些实际上维护和加剧不平等，而不是减轻不平等的事业。所以富人更有可能捐赠给母校。他们更有可能捐赠给各种倡议，甚至是那些迎合精英阶层、有助于维护上层阶级权力的文化机构，
individuals as opposed to trying to mitigate it. So I think it's a complicated answer. One of the questions I've gotten really interested in is the stories of wealth that people tell, particularly in the U.S. And so, for instance, something like the Giving Pledge gets a lot of traction in the news, right? Because people love hearing stories about how, you know, stereotypically speaking, wealthy or sometimes depicted as Scrooge's. But here we've got all this evidence, including Bill Gates and Warren Buffett, but so many other people of people being so philanthropic. And so newspapers, tell these stories. We tell these stories. We share them almost as like heroic tales. And so we've launched a set of studies that look at the role of these stories that we tell of wealthy heroes in getting
而不是试图减轻这种不平等。所以我认为这是一个复杂的答案。我非常感兴趣的问题之一是人们讲述的财富故事，特别是在美国。例如，“捐赠誓言”在新闻中获得了很大的关注，对吧？因为人们喜欢听关于富人如何被刻板印象描绘成“吝啬鬼”的故事。但在这里，我们有所有这些证据，包括比尔·盖茨和沃伦·巴菲特，以及许多其他人如此慷慨。所以报纸讲述这些故事。我们讲述这些故事。我们几乎把它们当作英雄传说来分享。因此，我们开展了一系列研究，探讨这些我们讲述的富人英雄故事在让
people to feel like, everyday people to feel like inequality might not actually be a problem. Because if it's the case that people who are wealthy are moral and good and pro-social and charitable and give their money away, well, then inequality. is not as problematic because those the wealth that's being concentrated on the top just ends up getting circulated around and benefiting everyone else. And we find that that's the case. The more people have been exposed to these stories, the more people tell them, the more okay with inequality people feel, which would suggest that there's actually possibly this kind of problematic, potentially problematic side to these stories of wealthy philanthropy. I don't think they're
普通人觉得不平等可能并不是一个真正的问题方面所起的作用。因为如果富人是道德高尚、亲社会、乐善好施并捐出钱财的人，那么不平等就不那么成问题了，因为集中在顶层的财富最终会流通并造福其他人。我们发现确实如此。人们接触这些故事越多，讲述这些故事的人越多，人们对不平等的接受度就越高，这表明这些富人慈善故事可能存在一种潜在的问题。我不认为它们
representative of our country's wealthy necessarily. And I think they bias the mind in some really interesting ways. I often like to close with the question of what you're working on next, but what are the big questions that you still want to answer? One that we're really interested in is how do your own narratives, your own experiences with wealth, how you earned it versus inherited it, play into the tendencies that we've really been interested in towards social connection, towards social attention, towards social attunement. So really looking at differences in inheritance versus earning in how we're
一定能代表我们国家的富人。我认为它们以一些非常有趣的方式偏向了人们的思想。我经常喜欢以“你接下来在研究什么”这个问题来结束，但你还有哪些想要回答的大问题？我们非常感兴趣的一个问题是，你自己的叙事，你自己的财富经历，你是如何赚取它的与继承它的，如何影响了我们一直感兴趣的对社会联系、社会关注、社会协调的倾向。所以我们真的在研究继承与赚取在财富如何
wealth seeps into the mind. And you pointed at this other really interesting piece, this emotional experience of guilt. And so we've been in the lab now for the last six or seven years, been looking at the role of guilt, particularly in a climate of growing inequality. The role of guilt in how people experience their wealth and how that guilt, those feelings of undeservingness, play into not only how someone feels about their wealth, but also what they're willing to do with it. So we've gotten interested in this idea of wealth guilt and where it comes from. And what are the ways that people go, what are the lengths that people go to assuage those feelings of guilt, to mitigate them and to even try to alleviate them, not only within themselves,
渗透进思想方面的差异。你指出了另一个非常有趣的方面，即内疚的情绪体验。因此，过去六七年来，我们一直在实验室里研究内疚的作用，特别是在不平等加剧的环境下。内疚在人们如何体验财富，以及这种内疚感、那些不配得感，不仅影响一个人对财富的感受，还影响他们愿意用财富做什么。所以我们对“财富内疚”这个概念及其来源产生了兴趣。人们为了缓解这些内疚感、减轻它们，甚至试图消除它们，会采取什么样的方式，不仅是在他们自己内心，
but to also sort of demonstrate that they themselves are deserving or not as wealthy as they might appear to be. But basically, what are the different ways that people kind of confront those feelings of guilt and navigate it in various social interactions? So those are two projects. And then more broadly, I've gotten really interested in different kinds of psychological, you might say, motivators that in some ways attenuate the wealth class differences we've been finding. So if it's the case that wealthier individuals, that elites are generally speaking biased toward conserving their privilege or conserving their power and are less attuned to the well-being of others and their social groups, then what are some factors that might
还要向外界证明他们自己是应得的，或者他们并不像看起来那么富有。但基本上，人们在各种社会互动中如何面对这些内疚感并应对它？这些是两个项目。更广泛地说，我对各种心理动机产生了浓厚的兴趣，这些动机在某种程度上减弱了我们发现的财富阶层差异。如果富人、精英阶层在总体上倾向于维护他们的特权或权力，并且对他人及其社会群体的福祉不太关注，那么有哪些因素可能会
attenuate those differences that get them to feel a heightened sense of responsibility toward the greater good to feel more compassion for their fellow citizens, their fellow group members. And so we've gotten interested in the role of compassion and more recently in how experiences of awe. And I don't just mean experiences that you might have in the Grand Canyon or looking up at the nightly sky, but experiences of awe sort of are characterized by feeling like you're a small part of something much bigger, how that kind of constellation of human experience can remind various people, not just wealthy people, but various people in various locations who belong to various groups, that they're not just these disconnected entities and disconnected individuals,
减弱这些差异，使他们对更大的利益产生更强烈的责任感，对同胞、同组成员产生更多的同情心？因此，我们对同情心的作用产生了兴趣，最近还研究了敬畏体验的作用。我指的不仅仅是在大峡谷或仰望夜空时可能有的体验，而是那种以感觉自己是更宏大事物的一小部分为特征的敬畏体验，这种人类体验的集合如何提醒各种人，不仅是富人，还有身处不同地点、属于不同群体的各种人，他们不仅仅是这些脱节的实体和孤立的个体，
but are rather interconnected bits of a much larger whole that are all sort of needing to work together toward unified goals. So how do experiences of awe sort of bring people together and allow us as a species to be better equipped to confront some of our most pressing challenges. Well, this is really interesting stuff that you're working on. I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been a pleasure talking to you, Dr. Piff. Thanks so much, Kim. It's been a lot of fun, and I mean that.
而是相互关联的更大整体的一部分，都需要为了统一的目标而共同努力。那么，敬畏体验如何将人们聚集在一起，使我们作为一个物种能够更好地应对我们最紧迫的一些挑战？好吧，你正在研究的东西真的很有趣。我想感谢你今天加入我。和你交谈很愉快，Piff 博士。非常感谢，Kim。这真的很有趣，我是认真的。
Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills.
谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方收听。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim 戴维斯。
Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list. and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
放松一下，让 Ralph's 的配送服务来处理您本周的杂货采购吧。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看您的清单，并仔细挑选每一件商品。接着我们打包好，并在短短 30 分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您订购的商品。新鲜杂货，随心所欲，尽在 Ralph's 配送和自提服务。现在，您的首次配送或自提订单可节省 20 美元。Ralph's，为每个人提供新鲜。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。